indra nooyi just said at the Washington
Economic Forum that the CEO the future
needs to know public policy as well as
they know no business needs to know
health as well as they know business and
so that the same thing firms need to be
creating people who are multi
civilization on multidisciplinary the
phrase she uses is sort of draws on a on
a classic philosopher that says we need
to create foxes not hedgehogs right
hedgehogs are very very deep in one
domain of knowledge foxes know a lot
about many many things and therefore can
wily in a wildly sense keep themselves
alive in the kind of world we find
ourselves in today
you have to be engaged in two mindsets
which are mutually contradictory the
first is clean the closet the second is
reinvent your wardrobe right put in
business terms get rid of all those
things that are no longer making money
that are no longer productive businesses
and engender innovation now one of these
that worries me a lot that's going on
the United States is we're doing a great
job of the former we're shrinking weary
cutting deals we're laying off employees
we're doing all sorts of stuff right but
but I don't see us investing in
innovation right so where's the money
that's going into creating new VC
alright so at the same time we've got
this huge stimulus package what Porsches
stimulus package is being put against
innovation I don't think it is basically
but there's a little bit in energy right
but mostly what we're doing is investing
in things we know work right and so the
nation needs to behave like a company in
this case which is we gotta trim we've
got to take the fat out and that means
we're going to have all sorts of social
consequences but the same time we've got
to invent the future right firms and you
do the same thing so the question of
should I control from the center or
should I encourage collaborate
innovation the periphery answer is yes
you